تم الكشف عن تشريح جثة فل هاوس ستار بوب ساجيت من
قبل الفاحص الطبي في
مقاطعة أورانج بولاية فلوريدا ، ووفقًا للتقرير ،
فإن السبب الرسمي للوفاة هو في الواقع
صدمة حادة في الرأس تنضم إلينا الآن هو
كبير المراسلين الطبيين
وجراح الأعصاب في CNN الدكتور سانجاي جوبتا
سانجي ، أعتقد أن هذا كان مفاجئًا  بالنسبة
لكثير من الناس ، ما يكشفه تقرير التشريح هذا ،
أعتقد أن ما يكشفه أكثر من
أي شيء آخر هو أن هذا لم يكن
نوعًا من النتوء البسيط في الرأس ، وأعتقد أن
ما سمعناه قبل يومين
هو أنه قد يكون السيد
ساغيت  لقد صدم رأسه نوعًا ما عندما
كان ينام في غرفته بالفندق
مما تسبب في معرفة حدوث
نزيف في دماغه ، ولكن عندما قرأت
تقرير التشريح هذا ، ربما لا يزال
هذا هو الحال ، لكنه كان بمثابة ضربة كبيرة
جدًا على رأسه  يمكنني أن أوضح لك أولاً وقبل
كل شيء أننا وضعنا هذا الرسم معًا فقط
لإعطائك فكرة باللون الأصفر لجميع
العظام المختلفة في جمجمته التي تعرضت
للكسر والتي تتطلب الكثير من القوة
للقيام بذلك والسماح  أريكم على نموذج الجمجمة
إذا كان بإمكاني أيضًا
أن تعلم بشكل أساسي أنه كان هناك كسور
في مؤخرة رأسه هنا
وأيضًا تآكل هنا لذلك من الواضح أنه
كان هناك نوع من التأثير الذي تعرفه
هنا أن الكسر امتد إلى
الصدغي الصحيح  عظم هنا ، لذلك
كان ذلك انتفاخًا صعبًا لفعل ذلك ، ولكن
ما لوحظ أيضًا في تقرير تشريح الجثة
هو وجود
كسور في الجمجمة في مقدمة جمجمته
هنا أيضًا فوق عينيه مباشرةً ، لذلك من
أجل القيام بذلك ،  يعني عندما
رأيت هذا لأول مرة إذا لم أكن أعرف شيئًا آخر
عما حدث ،
فستعتقد أنه ربما كان هذا
الشخص قد سقط على
الدرج ولديه العديد من الصدمات في الرأس أو
كان غير مقيد في حادث سيارة ،
أعني أنه كان بهذه الدرجة من  في
جراحة المخ والأعصاب ، غالبًا ما تنظر
إلى الطاقة التي تم نقلها فعليًا
إلى الجمجمة في الدماغ بالإضافة إلى
الآلية وتعلم كل ما حدث
هنا قد لا نعرف بالضبط
كيف سقط أو ما حدث.  لقد كانت
ضربة كبيرة تسببت في ذلك ومن
المحتمل أن يكون النزيف أعلى الدماغ
كما ترون هناك في هذه الصورة
يسبب ضغطًا على
الدماغ وبالتالي أدى للأسف
إلى فقدانه الوعي ثم وفاته ،
فما تعلمناه أكثر من أي شيء آخر  وإلا
كان هذا مهمًا مهما
حدث مهما حدث ، فقد كانت
ضربة كبيرة وليست شيئًا بسيطًا